I think they're two genders male and
female that's where I would have to
disagree okay saying that male and
female is something that uh would be by
birth for example uh you probably have a
penis a male sex org G as what I why
would you assume that do do you but you
assumed it though okay I did I did I
apologize it's interesting to me that
you assumed that I have a penis why uh
because you uh seem uh I don't know man
is it because of societal construct yes
that's why yes wasn't because of my bone
structure or my penis bulge let me ask
you this then what's the number how many
genders are there I couldn't tell you
isn't that important um gotch you